[Applause]
the killing of shireen abu aklay two
days ago has enraged the arab world
what happened today will do nothing to
calm the growing tensions
as her body was carried out of a
hospital in east jerusalem israeli
police attacked the pool bearers and the
coffin was almost dropped
[Applause]
less than an hour later outside the
catholic church as the funeral service
was going on
we watched israeli undercover police run
into the crowd to arrest mourners
there was no clear reason why
israel is already under international
pressure to explain how she was shot in
the west bank town of janine
these scenes broadcast live around the
world do not help israel's image right
now
shireen abalakley was highly respected
not just across the arab world but
particularly in palestine she covered
the israeli parasite conflicts for more
than two decades and whatever the
investigation says
the mourners here will not be swayed
they believe
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
tens of thousands of palestinians
followed the coffin through jerusalem
she was carried to a christian cemetery
on the walls of the old city and laid to
rest next to her mother and father
it's hard the thing that
the only thing is that if she will wake
up
and see how much people love her
and
and this beautiful city
is kind of palestinian today
to cover the generation of palestinians
grew up watching shireen abu ackley on
television
people even went without food just so
they could afford al jazeera to watch
her a friend told us
shireen abu aklay was a journalist and
she was killed as she did her job
reporting the news
alice at bunker sky news in jerusalem